in this video you're going to learn how
to apply to a full time editing position
here at corridor digital in Los Angeles
now don't go run it off and sending us
that email just yet because there's a
lot of important stuff in this video
that I want to make sure you get exactly
right so you have an equal opportunity
to get this job good luck
squeak squeakers welcome to the job
application video is with a heavy heart
that we've announced economic Jolla is
moving on to other endeavors but that
means we are now hiring and rather than
just doing the usual put out a notice on
a couple different job postings here in
LA I think our friends know we wanted to
open it up to everyone to the world you
want to let everyone know that this
position is available because we know
that out there there are some very
talented people that watch this channel
who wanted you to see this that's right
have you seen that movie with Mark
Wahlberg where he joins the Philadelphia
Eagles yeah this video is not intended
to be entertaining I'm just going to
give you an information dump and they're
gonna be straightforward with you and
that's what's gonna happen here when you
actually work here potentially that's
right and in order to get here into the
next round we're gonna go through the
very first round and the very first
round is so beautifully simple given
that we're gonna get a lot of
submissions we have a very simple format
for submitting please send us an email
to jobs at corridor digital calm in the
subject line put corridor job
application followed by a vertical line
followed by your first and last name in
the body of the email at the top again
put your first and last name underneath
that puts link followed by a colon
followed by a YouTube URL that takes us
to your edit of our footage how do I get
corridor digital's footage and edit it
in the top of the description of this
video is a link to a high tail server on
that server is footage that you are to
download edit
and upload to YouTube unlisted remember
make it unlisted why am i speaking like
a robot because if you do not follow
these instructions exactly I'm going to
immediately delete your application you
could be Steven Spielberg's editor and
it wouldn't matter because the first
thing that I need to know is that you
can follow the most basic instructions
first things first I know a lot of you
have been inspired to get into film from
watching us a lot of you have interests
in film and a lot of you are learning
about filmmaking because we try to teach
a lot of people things that we know this
is not a entry-level position this is
not a starting out cut your teeth learn
how to start editing position this is
not for you to apply for if you are just
leaving high school and are looking for
an editing gig this position you're
going to be taking here this is not a
job for us to have to train someone in
extensively we're not going to teach you
how to edit we're not going to teach you
how to use After Effects you there's so
many learning happening or so good
they're so gonna be training but the
training needs to be happening with you
already knowing how to edit already
knowing how to tell a story need to be a
technically proficient professional
editor that's where your editing skill
needs to be because that's what we're
going to be expecting those of you who
do want to learn are looking for those
opportunities the more entry-level
opportunities those do come up they will
happen again we do look for internships
in the summer all that kind of stuff but
back to what we're looking for here
first is the ability to tell a story
even with like the corridor crew channel
war it feels like it's just reality
didn't captured we are still telling a
story it means you are looking for what
is what is the interesting thing about
what I'm capturing why do I care what
are the elements I need to capture to
tell the story
you must understand storytelling both
narrative Lee and non narrative Lee
there's a lot of reality captured on
this channel it's not all just reality
capture but there's a lot of reality
capture if you watch reality television
and you understand how they're
constructing the show's to make you want
to watch the show to make you understand
the arcs of the characters that's a
great science ee-ee-ee-ee is cooking
shows all that watch a lot of cutthroat
kitchen that's a perfect example of
people are knowing how to make a story
out of reality the other thing that you
must possess you need to understand
which stories matter which stories
people will want to find out more
which stories will pull people in in
which stories won't for example you
might have a great story what does the
thumbnail look like what does the title
look like when is it appropriate to have
a title reference us and what is it
appropriate to have a title be very
general to bring more people in there's
a strategy to all these things now I
have a bunch of philosophies on that now
is not the time for me to go into them
if you are here we will talk about it
after that we'll take a good look
through all the submissions we'll pick
our favorite ones and then we will reach
out to each of you individually for
further rounds of the application we
hope to have this person in our studio
starting in January or at the very
latest in February and the nice thing
about having a global audience is we
don't care where you're from as long as
you're willing to move here for this job
you will have to move to Los Angeles do
not ask us if you can work remotely you
will have to be here in the studio every
day full-time yep not weekend's Monday
through Friday it's a it's a full-time
job based out of Los Angeles yeah now
the Edit we wanted to speak to your
skills as an editor we want you to tell
a story with that edit its footage that
we've picked up here for a segment that
is not on the corridor crew Channel and
we want you to do your best to show what
it would look like if you edited the
segment for the corridor crew channel
what does it look like how does it play
you're welcome to create your own
graphics and things like that that's
fully fine but just make a good segment
make it interesting
show us the voice and the perspective
you bring as an editor upload the videos
unlisted please why am I being so strict
about this because when we did the
internship application which eventually
wound up in us finding Peter we received
434 submissions and I made the mistake
of asking people to give open-ended
answers to questions and
meet through one less comment here the
Edit that you make of our footage we're
gonna be looking at a lot of these edits
I'm not expecting them to all
necessarily be necessarily be like
wildly different from each other so the
only thing I asks that you keep it tight
don't make it super long we're looking
for a proficiency here this is just
around one round two ism to get creative
I mean get creative and round one too
but keep it within the rep look my
direction can you work here good luck
I look forward to reviewing all of these
because I know there's somebody out
there and we're gonna find them and this
is your chance to tell your friends tell
your co-workers maybe don't tell them
because you want the job who knows but
either way have fun with it and good
luck see you out there